nous sommes aujourd'hui devant une
église ukrainienne orthodoxe rattachée
au patriarcat de moscou à environ une
trentaine kilomètres au sud de kiev nous
sommes venus ici pour parler aux fidèles
car l'invasion russe a déclenché un
conflit au sein de ce mouvement
religieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
christine a conquis
le problème à tort comme celui-ci les
catholiques sida barney stinson ce
qu'ils ont à dire
[Musique]
nous avons parlé à plusieurs fidèles et
on constate une prise de distance avec
les propos de leur chef l'ultime le
patriarche de moscou kirill
un peu plus tôt nous avons discuté avec
un porte parole de l'église orthodoxe
ukrainienne rattachée au patriarcat de
moscou qui a eu des mots très durs une
condamnation très claire de l'invasion
russe il a dénoncé je le cite un acte de
traîtrise il a dit qu'il fallait
défendre le pays
[Musique]
c'est un désaveu cinglant pour le
président russe vladimir poutine qui a
longtemps utilisé le prétexte religieux
pour justifier l'invasion du trend
[Musique]